good morning again and welcome i am
cynthia roman curator of prints drawings
and paintings at the louisville pol
library for those of you who don't know
me but I think I actually know everybody
out there thank you for being here this
morning I hope more people were gonna
join us later recovery maybe from the
wonderful performance last night so
these two days of the mysterious mother
programs have been part of a series of
celebrations sponsored by the Louisville
pol library in this instance partnering
with the Yale Center for British art to
celebrate the tercentenary of Horace
Walpole's birth which was actually last
September 24th I hope I got that right
I'm horrible with dates Steven is it the
24th so this is the last of the series
of programs that Jonathan kramnik the
Maynard Mac professor of English and
director of the Lewis Walpole library
has conceived as the walpa lose a year
and it was it commenced appropriately
not that Strawberry Hill with the
Walpole wallow last fall events also
included a mini conference on the Castle
of Otranto that Jonathan organized at
the Lewis Walpole library and later in
the fall George Haggerty distinguished
professor of English at UC Riverside
delivered a lecture on the many lives of
Horace Walpole and led a workshop in a
roundtable on biography inquiry archives
and we did an exhibition and a two-day
conference on global encounters and the
archives Britain's global Empire in the
age of Horace Walpole
with which was organized with Steve
Pincus and some yellow graduate students
so I just want to say a particular thank
you to Jonathan for his strong support
of the staging of this mysterious mother
the idea has been brewing for a really
long time yours actually and it's been
embraced by with lots of enthusiasm from
so many at the Lewis Walpole library
fellows who have contributed so
essentially their ideas and energies to
realizing these programs and they I
think I've had conversations with
everyone who is AM possess and to has
participated and just to say it's really
wonderful for me to be part of this
community of scholars in Walpole
enthusiasts every single one of whom
from the very earliest notion responded
with a unhesitating and resounding yes I
absolutely want to be part of that so
thank you all for that
so I hope I think actually looking out
there everyone was part of the audience
fantastic fantastic performance or stage
grieving of the mysterious mother last
night and again thank you to misty for
bringing that all together and our
performers and I hope that you were all
as entertained and captivated as as I
was but any of your friends and
colleagues who have missed it it was
recorded it is being recorded today so
make sure everyone knows it will be
posted and Sue will make sure that the
word is spread so and we'd actually
think that this was the first North
American performance for sure and one of
the rare public performances generally
and we're gonna hear more about that
from our distinguished panel later
so today's mini conference is jointly
organized by jill campbell professor of
english at Yale and a favorite faculty
partner for the Lewes Walpole library
Jill I I just by way of a little
anecdote included the mysterious mother
in her orals reading list when she was
examined by ron paulson so she's been a
longtime fan I guess of the mister
and published an essay I am no giant
horace walpole and a heterosexual incest
and love among men in 1998 which still
continues to be cited so before I turn
over to Jill who's gonna chair the first
panel I just want to acknowledge those
who have contributed so much
starting with horace walpole himself in
his wonders and his prolific and diverse
legacy and of course WS lewis and his
wife annie Baraka and Klaus Lewis whose
lifework whose vision for a Study Center
for 18th for the 18th century in
Farmington and his bequest their request
to Yale has ensured Walpole's legacy and
allowed us to host wonderful events like
this and of a serious fellowship program
also to the staff at the Lewis at the
Yale Center for British art in
particular Jane no Asako who's been so
wonderful helping us organize and plan
this 2bath miller deputy director for
advancement who supported us and of
course
- Amy Meyer who always warmly welcomes
these kinds of programs and generously
supports the Lewis Walpole library - the
AV staff up there in the booth thank you
so much to Yale broadcast services and
of course we all know that none of this
is possible without the extraordinary
work and dedication of the staff at the
Lewis Walpole library who most of you
know because you've been there in
particular sue Walker head of public
services and Michelle Prive senior
administrative assistant and also of
course thank you to Nicole Boucher our
executive director so thank you again
for joining us today to explore the many
facets of reading and staging wall post
play I won't comment too much myself
except to say that I personally find the
mysterious mother a particularly
compelling story
of deep anxiety personal social
political even religious and I don't
know maybe that's more about me but I
look forward today's explanation and
complexities of Walpole's vision and its
reception among our speakers today so
Jill good morning and welcome I want a
second
Cyndi's thanks to all the people dead
and living that made our coming together
possible this morning thank you all for
coming back this morning after last
night's very exciting creative gripping
funny over-the-top and yet powerful and
thought-provoking performance we're very
fortunate today to have a rich array of
scholars who can address for us a number
of facets of the questions raised by
this strange and remarkable play this
morning session is about reading the
mysterious mother we're going to be
attending to its history as a written
text and some of the interpretive
questions the full text raises as you
know last night's performance was
brilliantly adapted in the bridge by
David Worrell so that it would be
playable and that really worked and it
was so interesting to hear him talk in
the talkback after the performance
yesterday about is with the the through
line of melodrama that he found and so
much that needed to fall away in making
it the kind of play a playable drama
that we enjoyed and experienced the
speakers this morning in this afternoon
are going to be addressing the full text
of the mysterious mother which is at
least twice as long as what we heard
last night maybe more than twice as long
so they're going to be talking about
passages and the the ways the play
entertains a variety of kinds of
questions and problems that that may not
have been fully evident in the gripping
drama you saw last night just a word
about format I'm going to be introducing
each speaker individually so popping
back and forth and they'll be presenting
their their five relatively short papers
and then we have Cindy and I have
planned lots of time for the speakers
then to come together to sit at the
front and have a Q&A among themselves
but also with all of you so we really
hope for an extended period of
discussion and just before I introduce
Dale I want to take this moment to shine
a spotlight on Cindy sitting there
because this has been just a just kind
of wonderfully deeply gratifying and fun
collaboration for all the people who've
been involved with Cindy is the one who
made it all happen who kept making sure
that all the connections were made and
that people's creative and scholarly
energies could be brought into this so
we are indebted to Cindy our first
speaker this morning - a townshend
appeared making I'm sure a deep
impression on you as Peter the Porter
last night wearing a wonderful feathered
cap and high leather boots playing his
important role in that catastrophic
drama in his ordinary life he is
professor of Gothic literature in the
center for Gothic studies at Manchester
Metropolitan University in the UK he's
published widely on gothic writing at
the late 18th and early 19th centuries
and has recently completed two studies
of the relationship between Gothic
architecture and Gothic literature in
the period writing Britain's ruins
co-edited with Michael Carter and Peter
Linfield and gothic antiquity history
romance and the architectural
imagination 1760 to 1840 which is
forthcoming next year so you can see
this is with that interest in Gothic
architecture and Gothic literature this
is this is a scholar that
that horace walpole demands and needs
and he will be speaking to us on the
mystery of the mysterious mother textual
lives and after lives
thank you very much Jill and thank you
to everyone for coming but special
thanks to Nicole and to Cindy and to
Michelle and Sue and Jill and Jonathan
and Jane sounds a bit like a poem that
I'm about to read but thank you to
everyone it's a great pleasure to be
here
March the 15th 1768 I finished a tragedy
called the mysterious mother which I'd
begun December the 25th 1768 but I'd
laid it aside for several months while I
went to Paris and while I was writing my
historic dots on the reign of Richard
the third the last two acts were not now
as much finished as I intended
thus wrote Horace Walpole in short notes
of the life of Horatio Walpole a draft
autobiographical account of his life his
letters and his most formative
experiences to date that he drew up in
1779
now it's often forgotten that the
mysterious mother was not well Paul's
first foray into drama and Norwood had
proved to be his last as early as June
17 43 he'd published in the journal Old
England the dear witches a short
dramatic reworking of Macbeth that
figured his father Sir Robert Walpole as
the Duncan like victim to a cabal of
political assassinators and later in
1773 he wrote a short comedy nature will
prevail which was performed at the
Little Theatre in the Haymarket in June
1775 and he published this together with
two very interesting essays entitled
thoughts on tragedy and thoughts on
comedy and volume two of his posthumous
works in 1798 and we remember that
thoughts on tragedy had initially been
formulated in letters to the dramatist
Robert Jefferson in 1775 the same
playwright who would later produce a
dramatic high
of both the Castle of Otranto and the
mysterious mother in the count of
Narbonne of 1780 81 so
completed by the middle of March 1768
the mysterious mother was immediately
dispatched in manuscript form to some
worple's closest friends and within a
month it had gratifyingly received the
approbation of his Oracle of taste of
course John shoot who is not easily
pleased and Thomas grey who is still
more difficult but as you would not bear
the subject he continued in a letter to
George Montagu in April of that year I
will say no more of it before somewhat
curiously claiming that I am not yet
intoxicated enough with it to think it
would do for the stage though I wish to
see it acted so whirlpools expression
here of ambivalent if not altogether
paradox paradoxical sentiments that is
his desire to see the play acted without
it being performed on stage is central I
would argue to the mysterious mother and
sentiments that are thirdly further
evidenced in his making of really quite
specific plans for the involvement of
his friends in the reading performance
and visual representation of the play
among them of course
Katherine Clive Hannah Pritchard William
Mason and Diana Baur Clarke
even as he continuously decries it's
horrid disgusting and ultimately
unperformed subject matter so upon
learning the year after its completion
that friends of Montague had eagerly
consumed the copy of the play that wall
pilot sent him Walpole is citing a line
from Henry the fourth part one wrote
that I beg you would keep it under lock
and key it is not at all food for the
public at least not till I am food for
words good Percy now I think this thus
begins a kind of complex process of
disclosure and obfuscation publication
and suppression the assertion and the
concealment of authorial identity
that characterizes the textual life of
the play from the moments of its
completion onwards between the 14th of
June and the 6th of August of that year
1768 Walpole prints 50 copies of the
script at Strawberry Hill now this in
itself I think is a significant public
publishing choice unlike at Rancho which
you know in order to maintain the
antiquarian conceit of the discovered
document had been published by Thomas
lands in London's and three-and-a-half
years before the mysterious mother was
literary property that required tight
regulation and control so printed
versions consequently were distributed
to only a select few of Walpole's most
trusted friends among them Thomas
Barrett's Richard Bull and Diana Bo
Clarke
now Walpole's manuscript annotations in
the copy that he sends to bull indicate
the extent to which he policed the
circulation of the printed text this is
what he writes mr. Walpole has sent mr.
bull the only copy he has left on the
play
but begs to have it returned as soon as
he is read it and that he will not let
it go out of his hands but later in June
1779 when Walpole eventually allows
Horace Mann to see a copy of the play
that he had long discussed in letters to
him he similarly asked that it be
returned to him via post all the way
from Florence Sir Walpole's reluctance
to part with printed scripts encouraged
people to make of it manuscript copies
and at least seven of these manuscript
copy fair copies are held at the Lewis
Walpole library today however so as to
forestall the publication of a spurious
and unauthorized edition of the play the
upsetting news of which he had received
from the actor John Henderson Walpole
reluctantly gave his consent to J Dodds
Lee in London to publish the mysterious
mother in 1781 as he wrote in a suitably
gothic idiom too cold my tragedy has
wandered into the hands of some banned
EG book
sellers and I'm forced to publish it to
myself to prevent piracy all I can do is
condemn it myself and that I shall so
unlike the first Strawberry Hill edition
of 1768 this second edition bought no
mention of Walpole on its title page but
included instead a one and a half page
preface that stressed the undisclosed
authors partly sincere partly faux
modest reluctance to bring it to public
view and you can see this on the slide
all the favor the author solicits or
expects he writes is to be believed how
unwillingly he is submitted to its
appearance he cannot be more blamed than
he blames himself for having undertaken
so disagreeable a story and for having
hazarded hazarded the publicity by
letting it get out of his own hands
there's a lot of talk about hands in
this round display so happily the mere
advertising of this forthcoming
authorized Edition was enough to
forestall the intended piracy so what
happens is that the 1781 text though
it's printed never actually proceeds to
publication and Walpole is now content
to give copies of this 1781 addition to
some of his friends in lieu of the first
edition of 1768 so having read this 1781
Edition and urging its immediate
theatrical production David Erskine
Baker in 1782 writes that knowing its
merits we cannot but express our
surprise that its author should wish to
withhold it from the public but I think
by 1785 Walpole is very clearly aware of
the fact that the play had become
somewhat of a collector's object or a
rarity in fact I'd go so far as to say
he actively courted the sense of
intrigue that this entailed but the the
texts publication history does not end
here
November 1781 extracts of the play that
had purportedly been leaked from a
manuscript copy were published in this
and James's Chronicle now the
the newspapers reprinting of act 1 scene
1 and 5 was preceded by lines that
demonstrate that the mysterious mother
had come to be regarded as highly
desirable literary property made all the
more so by the mystery the secrecy the
exclusivity that surround its its
circulation this is what the reprinting
of those two scenes from act 1 is
preceded by an anonymous correspondent
has highly favoured this in James
Chronicle by the following desirable
specimen of an unpublished performance
which in the dramatic world we are truly
sensible is held as a first-rate
curiosity an internet word curiosity as
a kind of antiquarian object but the
same paper followed up this piracy one
week later this time publishing act 3
scenes 1 & 3 & act 4 scene 4 in the
regular Poets Corner column preface
extract swith a similar affirmation of
the place status as a rare yet highly
desirable artifact to the printer of
thus in James's chronicles sir your
readiness to oblige induces me to
transcribe for your poets corner another
speech or two from an invaluable
manuscript whilst it remains in my
possession now further extracts are
printed in the public advertiser in
November 1781 again in 1783
but it's this latter 1783 leakage of
aspects of the text that prompts Walpole
to write to the publisher Henry Sampson
would fall in request of its immediate
suppression even offering him financial
compensation for any imaginary benefit
he says that he might receive from the
impression at this time writes Walpole
the public must be curious to see more
interesting articles than scenes of an
old tragedy on a disgusting subjects a
play which the author thinks so little
worthy of being published that after the
first small impression he is endeavoured
to suppress it as much as lies in his
power 1790 Walpole learned through
Joseph Cooper Walker of another pirate
addition of the text but this time in
Dublin in the meantime without Walpole's
knowledge Lord Sala wanted suppress this
publication on the agent authors behalf
and while Walpole remained enormously
grateful towards his protector he had
become by this time quite exhausted by
the entire debacle I have lived too long
not to have divested myself both the
vanity and affected Manas modesty very
interesting for his affected modesty he
writes to Charlemont in' in February
1791
I've not existed to past 73 without
having discovered the futility and
trifling nough sub my own talents and at
the same time it would be impertinent
quick change of rhetorical direction to
pretend to think that there is no merits
in the execution of a tragedy on which I
had been so much flattered though I am
sincere in condemning the egregious
absurdity of selecting a subject so
improper for the stage and even
offensive to private readers dot-dot-dot
I will beg your lordship if you please
to signify to the bookseller that you
withdraw your prohibition so I'll be it
with Walpole's very big grudgingly
granted consent the mysterious mother
was duly published in Dublin by Archer
Jones and white in 1791 Walpole's name
only mentioned in a cited extracts from
a description of the play that had first
been published in biographic dramatical
in 1782 now a poem which I believe has
been reprinted on the back of your
program for today by one Florizel that
was published in the world
on Wednesday the 12th of October 1791
indicates something of the public
approbation with which the eventual
publication of this mysterious piece was
met Walpole for this anonymous poet at
least had restored the spirits of gothic
genius that had last been seen on the
English stage in Shakespeare's plays so
there's a reprint of the Dublin Edition
that is published in London in 1791
which this time features Walpole's nay
on the title page and another edition
follows in 1796 now after so many years
of resistance walpole consents to the
publication of the mysterious mother in
the first volume of his posthumous works
that Barry oversees including in volume
4 a hitherto unpublished prologue that
had been written in 1768 now of course
if publication is a matter of such
urgency and anxiety performances
inconceivable although as I've suggested
there is evidence to suggest that well
people did seriously contemplate its
production an appreciative man summed up
the views of Walpole in his miller when
he wrote that the subject may be too
horrid for the stage but the judicious
management of it by preparing the reader
for the catastrophe the sublime ideas
and expressions so admirably adapted to
the personages make it a delicious
entertainment for the closet so in
Walpole's lifetime as we know it remains
a closeted drama the likes of goethe's
faust or later verse dramas of Byron and
Shelley and as such as intended only to
be read by a solitary reader or
sometimes out aloud in a small group
variously with or without the author's
knowledge or consent what is intriguing
is the many accounts of these reading
experiences that remain my favorite is
by the Scottish antic Reed John
Pinkerton who recalls in well poliana of
1799 a chilling nighttime reading of
whirlpools tragedy at Strawberry Hill on
the 20th of September 1784 the occasion
on which Walpole leaves him alone we
believe with the script at 11:00 p.m.
while he calls upon a neighbor now his
wall pollen and Pinkerton both know the
date of this reading 20th September is
in itself highly significant because it
uncannily marks the anniversary of that
night so many years before on which the
count of Narbonne was gored to death by
the wild stag the night on which the
contest seduced
but then banished her son Edmund and
also the night on which Edmund returns
to knob on exactly 16 years later I
think another uncanny
coincidence that was Walpole's decision
to call upon catherine or kitty clive on
this night the 20th September 1784 of
all nights as we know it was the Clive
the famed comic actress who was to speak
the epilogue to the play another
decision that portrays I think will pols
intentions to see it performed from 1753
the Clive had been living in Twickenham
at little Marble Hill a property owned
by Walpole himself and upon her
retirement from the stage in 1769 she
moved to little Strawberry Hill later
known as Cliveden another Twickenham
property within the vicinity of
Strawberry Hill that Walpole had built
in 1768 and which he generously gifted
to her so 20th September 1784 Pinkerton
reader reads Walpole's play at
Strawberry Hill thus marking the kind of
random congruence of a number of factors
that were intimately related to
Whirlpool's tragedy this odd
circumstance writes Pinkerton conspired
with the complete solitude of the gothic
apartments to lend an additional
impression to the superstitious parts of
that tragedy in point of language and
the true expression of passion and
feeling the new and just delineation of
monastic fraud tyranny and cruelty it
deserves the greatest praise now of
course another well-known record of a
reader's engagement with the play comes
from the court journals of Francis
Burnie in 1786 in which Burnie recounts
her shocked even traumatized reactions
to a group reading of the play at
Windsor Castle merely four months after
her arrival at courts just to pick out a
few lines for myself I felt a sort of
indignant aversion rise fast and warm in
my mind against the wilful author of a
story so horrible all the entertainment
and pleasure I'd received from mr.
Walpole seemed extinguished by his
lecture which almost made me regard him
as the patron of the vices he had been
pleased to record now I think what
happens is that through these and other
such whisper
accounts the the width held play
achieves something of a mythological
status in all his reluctance to share
its walpole the best-selling author of
at Rancho had clearly made a mystery of
the mysterious mother and thus we might
begin to track the afterlife of the play
in romantic eerie Britain in 1792 in the
preface to her play the massacre the
radical writer Elizabeth inch bald came
at her own decision to write and publish
the play yet withhold it from production
was directly informed by the precedent
that Walpole had set in the mysterious
mother but I
to conclude the the influence of
Walpole's play goes well beyond the late
18th century stage as a primarily
textual phenomenon in its day its
natural destination I think were the
prose genres of Romantic era fiction I
think the play opens up imaginative
possibilities that later gothic fiction
would come to exploit for it was in a
drama with such as if for it was a drama
without which such later gothic
representations of brother sister incest
in say Matthew loses the monk of 1796
would not have been possible and
Radcliffe twice used extracts from the
play as epigraphs
to the Italian of 1797 reworking the
relationship between the countess and
father Benedict in that between the
Marchesa diva vol D and the notorious
villain Father shadow knee later
romantics were equally enamored of it in
the preface to Marino faliero Byron
praised it as a tragedy of the highest
order and not a pooling love play
Walpole he continued is the father of
the first romance at Rancho and of the
last tragedy in our language and surely
worthy of a higher place than any other
living writer be he who he may Walter
Scott
was altogether less enthusiastic when he
anthologized the play in Ballantine's
modern British drama in 1811 later in
lives of the novelists Scot would pass
the play as a horribly impressive but
disgusting drama so irrespective of
whether it was revered or reviled one
might sincerely ponder the extent to
which some of the greatest sexually
transcript xed s-- of canonical
Romanticism and here I'm thinking of
Shelley's the chen chih-wei on Sydnor or
Mary Shelley's Matilda and especially
the double incest plot of John Paul II
Doris an ester Spurr child possibly even
Byron's manfred would have been possible
without the mysterious mother and that
cultivated sense of secrecy and mystery
that surrounded thank you
[Applause]
thank you so much Dale our next speaker
is Matthew M Reeve he is associate
professor of art history and queens
national scholar at Queen's University
in a fellow of the Society of
Antiquaries working in both the medieval
and modern periods
he has just completed a revisionist
account of Gothic architecture sexuality
and aesthetics in the circle of horace
walpole
it will be coming out in 2019 and it
follows from essays in the art bulletin
architectural history the Burlington
magazine and other venues Matthew will
be speaking to us on the mysterious
mother and crypto Catholicism in the
circle of Horace Walpole anyway thank
you very much for having me here and to
our wonderful support and I want to also
think really really quickly the Lois
Walpole library because they gave me my
start on this project in a wonderful way
over a summer fellowship and they also
taught me how to play professional
croquet which was an amazing thing those
of you who've been there know exactly
what I'm talking about
now as you've heard this is a special
treat for me to be here because I'm not
officially an English specialist nor an
18th century in fact but an art
historian and a medievalist and my
interest in Walpole in his homoerotic
circle of male friends and designers and
patrons concerned their pivotal role in
the shaping of the Gothic idiom in the
18th century in their art writing their
arcs and architectural Patridge
particularly and in my case tangentially
their literature so although it's seldom
understood as such while Polian gothic
as an historical idiom confronted and
was informed by its historical roots in
medieval Catholicism in England the
official end of Catholicism with the
16th century dissolution of the
monasteries established a fundamental
break in religious structures and by
many accounts including that of Horace
Walpole its heritage in Gothic
architecture Walpole's gothic reflects a
complex response to Catholicism it was
variously critical
erotic romantic and even erotic but like
many Goths and Antiquaries before and
after him it is motivated fundamentally
if not straightforwardly by mourning for
a lost spiritual and aesthetic past so
in setting this up I want to say a
little bit first of all about Walpole's
appraisal of Catholicism and then ask
how this might this context might inform
a reading of the mysterious mother it
goes without saying that few men within
Walpole's circle were either Catholic or
Catholic converts they can be more
usefully understood as crypto Catholics
Walpole described himself as a
Protestant goth and a strain of
anti-catholicism runs through his
writing as of course it does to the
period itself yet he felt no tension in
writing to Reverend William Cole saying
things like I like potpourri as well as
you do and I've shown that I do I like
it like I like chivalry and romance they
all furnish one with ideas and visions
which Presbyterianism does not a gothic
church a convent fills one with romantic
dreams
Walpole playfully allegorized Strawberry
Hill is a Catholic shrine calling it a
gothic Vatican of Greece and Rome and he
was clear that aspect of his interiors
were intentional approximations of the
splendor and godliness to use his word
of medieval Catholic art with all the
glory of popery Walpole in his circle
actively and playfully explored the
Catholic and quasi religious nature in
the houses that they built the
Strawberry Hill oratory for example was
a function less exterior prayer Anish
enclosed within iron rails with basins
for holy water and a 15th century bronze
angel Walpole's famous letter of 1753 to
Horace Mann describes his plans for his
new monastery at Strawberry Hill thus he
says I am greatly impatient for my altar
and so far from mistrusting its goodness
I only fear it will be too good to
expose to the weather as I intend it to
be a recess in the garden I was going to
tell you that my house is so monastic
that I have a little Hall decked with
long lean Saints in lean arched windows
and with long columns that we call the
Pericles and memory of the noises
cloister now this is typical
the range of religious significations
and frankly in jokes that he and his
circle shared in which Catholicism its
rights settings and rituals were
subjects of a highly nuanced coterie
taste and understanding he concludes
with a reference to the Paraclete or the
entrance-hall as i show it to you here
the name of which is borrowed from pope
Cilla's and Abelard of 1717 of course
elsewhere in describing Dickie Bateman
his kind of frenemy as we might say
these days at his building of his gun
his Thames villa and by the strawberry
hill designers Walpole claims and I
quote that Batemans Villa had changed
its religion I converted it I converted
it from Chinese to gothic and that his
monkish chambers were always dressed as
though in full mourning unquote these
men would develop a rich series of
tropes to describe themselves as brother
monks Abbot's and their houses as
nunneries and monasteries and so forth
they would also perform their crypto
Catholic prove that crypto Catholicism
excuse me through faux liturgies at the
vine in Hampshire with ancient Mass
books and incense where they had what
they called quote unquote a most
Catholic enjoyment of the chapel their
quotation I'm still trying to understand
Walpole could allegorize no I really am
well who could allegorize a visit to
Strawberry Hill by George Montagu as the
festival of st. George and speak of the
gorgeous Saints and stained glass he
acquired and so forth and so on and so
on
so Catholicism and the Gothic shared a
common temporal location in Walpole's
historiography this is an important
point ie variously up to and even after
1540 particularly with reference to
literature and Shakespeare as we heard
yesterday for Walpole both were
associated with the form of sensory
ethical and libidinal freedom what he
called visionary enjoyments a state of
being he felt was diminished by the
extinction of Catholicism chivalry of
the Gothic style itself with the
dissolution of the monasteries as an
historical moment of rupture and change
he considers the dissolution and
Protestantism itself to reflect a reform
of human emotional and intellectual as
thesis reform in other words was not a
good thing for Horace Walpole in
architecture the classicism that
followed the dissolution
was replaced pardon me dissolution
replace the Gothic in Walpole's
developmental theory in other words the
English Renaissance and this was
understood by him as a destructive
reform of the built environment that was
the result of stifled human aesthetic
agency of creativity being hemmed in by
the oppressive rules of classicism or
reform or Protestantism as his argument
follows the Gothic becomes a style in a
period of unrestrained creativity a
space with a free unfiltered and
unregulated projection of the
imagination as such a revival of the
Gothic Mensa not simply returned to the
forms of later medieval architecture but
also to its spiritual and performative
modes or at least a particularly
specific and camp even conception of
them and of course in this he has his
critics Madame dated foreign would
respond to the mysterious mother by
stating I do not like Abelard and Eloise
at all something in this case she
connects to the play whether ancient or
modern her endearments her passions are
not my style
Wolpaw responds noting that the play is
presented as a kind of Gothic which
would not be found in your other words
French theater a kind of polite dropping
of the mic if there ever was one as a
subversive other mode of spiritual and
political allegiance within to
Protestant England Catholicism and non
normative sexuality were marked by a
history of trop illogical substitution
and inter implication for contemporary
audiences offering the fantasy of a
monosexual culture many of the gothis
isms in Walpole's circle suggest queer
appropriations of Catholic rituals and
aesthetics beneath the cowl of
monasticism was a cult of male
homoerotic community indeed the cloister
has been usefully understood as a
preparatory space for the closet and
modern constructions of homosexuality in
recent research no so much is clear but
too nuanced this point and it does need
a lot of nuanced monasticism was also
used as a guise to perform overtly
heterosexual license as in the case of
Sir Francis Dashwood and the madman
amongst just up the Thames from
Strawberry Hill who performed there
orgiastic exploits with nuns
quote-unquote nuns
within Gothic settings the so called
Hellfire Ches and we can of course
tres is such an association between
Catholicism and alternate or unreformed
sexuality across many cultural
productions contemporaneously including
this newly acquired sprint here at the
Lewis walpole library and thanks to
Cindy for descending this honor we just
got this about a week ago so Walpole's
use of gothic to describe the mysterious
mother in his own crypto Catholic
practices aside such as they may be what
does this have to do with the play well
superficially at least the continental
gothic past or Catholic past excuse me
becomes a space that normalizes or at
least makes possible radical sexual
difference it facilitates the story
central narrative of incest as a
Freudian family romance safely removed
from a contemporary English context and
here I'm recalling George haggerty's
remarkable observation that the
monastery functions as a precursor to
the laboratory in Georgian culture at
the space to explore and examine sexual
difference the plays over at focus on
Catholicism it's rites it's apparently
villainous clerics and associations has
stood at the center of the plays
reception from Paul Baines view of
Horace Walpole's what he calls a
manifestly and her sake d'etre soccer
total focus excuse me to a 1797 critique
which stated that and I quote mr.
Walpole was a bitter foe to priests
without distinction and seems to have
had no great reverence for sacred
mysteries or the doctrinal parts of the
Christian system but I want to follow
Walpole here himself in his famous post
get in which he says I quote the
villainy of Benedict was planned to
divide the indignation of the audience
and intercept some of it from the
countess nor will the blackness of his
character appear extravagant if we call
to mind the crimes committed by Catholic
Church men when the Reformation not only
provoked their rage but threatened them
with total ruin so while the play
clearly exploits the ready cliches of
Vilnius or Life sumptuous classic
Catholic clergy Walpole goes some way I
think to historic eyes and even
justified Benedict's actions in this
passage the monks really are the victims
of a changing tide so in one sense the
play turns on the
14 eventual demise of Kath Catholicism's
very structures in this sense near bond
is like TS Eliot's wasteland suffering a
period of moral and physical decline
after the transgression of 16 years
previous the countess has largely
neglected her traditional role as a
benefactor to the Abbey and as a result
it is partially ruinous but more
importantly as Benedict understands it
she has neglected her spiritual role to
her priest and confessor Benedict
continually reaches out to her but she
shuns and mocks him knowing that the
church could never correct or contain
her sin here the often cited parallel
between the medieval confessional as a
precursor to the modern psychiatry sofa
seems apt since religion grandly
declines and is even replaced with the
rise of psychoanalysis to follow one
narrative anyway having for all intents
and purposes fired her psychiatrist in
the sense the countess has disrupted the
traditional epistemological relationship
between the family and their faith thus
upsetting the structures of knowledge
and power in medieval Catholicism and as
a result it is the castle and not the
monastery that becomes the physical
container and site for the exploration
of trauma unmediated by Catholic
confession and this might help us to
understand what why Walpole locates the
plot in the liminal space of the
Reformation rather than the period of
the Crusades as a note rant ho the
Reformation not only historicize --is
the actions of the Catholic clergy but
it FEMA ties 'as them as well and so too
does the position that countess's very
subjectivity between an exterior piety
consonant with Catholic confession and
an interior redemptive piety consistent
with Protestantism and as Dale and I
discussed last night perhaps she was
already the process of conversion
herself so if I'm hinting here at a
strain of apology or something like
apology and wall post construction of
the Catholic unless the Gothic past I do
so for a good reason
Walpole and medievalists at his
generation inherited and
historiographical tradition from their
early modern antiquarian predecessors
people like John Stowe and William
Dugdale and others that look to the
dissolution as a fundamental break in
the religious and social character of
the country and yearn for a return to
the pre dissolution
past walpole absorbed these ideas and
made them central to his home even used
various now lost monuments illustrated
in Doug's Dale's text to become the
gothic installations at Strawberry Hill
thereby imprinting to use wall poles own
word this nostalgic vision of the
Catholic past upon the inside of his
famous home and I just give you a second
example here that's a little bit more
pleasant to look at no waffles crypto
Catholicism was of course a tangled and
ambivalent aspect of his historicism of
his very nostalgia he could for example
offer a lament upon seeing King's
College Chapel at Cambridge again after
some years he says that penetrated me
with a visionary longing to be a monk in
it a pretty odd comment to be sure for a
collegiate rather than a monastic
foundation but here as elsewhere in all
of this I think that we fail at Walpole
and taking him literally and reducing
his writings too legalistic documents
that prove or not specific ideas rather
than interrogating them with his own
language now I want to close with a
passage from a wonderful book Michael
and Holly's recent book The Melancholy
arse in which she describes the art
historians own subjective position
against her own historical subject a
passage that I think might usefully
gloss Walpole's own historicism via Pisa
V the Catholic past and she says
nostalgia is simply not capacious enough
a word to name the source of this
sensation this homesickness of things
what we momentarily encounter there is
the living pulsating afterlife of the
past thank you
[Applause]
Thank You Matthew
our next speaker is Nicole Garrett she's
a part-time faculty member at SUNY Stony
Brook and Adelphi University and a
recent Lois Walpole library fellow
nicole has co-edited two novels of
Francis Sheridan's the sydney biddle
novels that are available through broad
view and also co-authored several essays
on 19th century religious enthusiasm dr.
Garrett's current research is on
literary and cultural narratives of
maternal grief and discourses of
consolation in the long eighteenth
century her paper today is titled miss
reading in the mysterious mother thank
you
I don't know what makes me more nervous
this room or this microphone okay I want
to thank of course the Louis Walpole
library
and Cindy Roman and all of the support
that you've given me over the past two
years or so I will never forget and
never stop coming back as long as I'm
invited okay
so the mysterious mother is a funny play
in several ways as horace walpole was
fond of saying the world is a comedy to
those that think in a tragedy to those
that feel and his play does seem to be a
reflection of the world as he saw it and
may be easy to miss the comedic aspects
of the play especially in rereading
because there's so much to wonder at in
the I'm sorry there's there's so much to
wonder at in the the subject of the
mother-son incest the comedy like the
tragedy is a product of characters miss
reading both signs in nature and the
mysterious mother herself in a letter to
William Mason in 1769 Walpole stated his
aim was to quote present a character
whose penitents was not degraded by
superstitious bigotry unquote of course
William Mason wanted him to try to
change the fact that change
his characters deliberate going to bed
with our son and make it a little bit
more palatable in that sense walpole
needed to expose and satirize bigotries
and Piatt ease that generate comic or
tragic miss readings so when the monks
Martin and Benedict shudder at a funeral
Church thinking it's a voice beyond the
grave saying forbear we laugh but when
others mystery the countess is a mother
who's supposedly natural maternal
instincts have become corrupted by
meddling priests the effect can be
tragic so I'd like to do in my short
time as look at the function of bigotry
as an interpretive lens how in it it in
effect shields the countess from
discovery of her sins and finally how
about both Clark drawings expressed
Walpole's themes without testing the
readers tolerance for mother-son incest
or what might be called our bigotries
and piety in the beginning the
mysterious mother is mysterious because
she's improper she's a bad mother she
defies expectations and she fails to
provide for needs nobody really knows
the countess we don't even learn her
first name unusually she has no
confidant or lady-in-waiting her
reputation is the product of rumor and
miss reading Benedict's is her would-be
confessor at first only knows her enough
to know he can't quite figure her out
her interpreters either read her as a
hardened heretic or having an
overabundance of feminine piety
furthermore they see her relationship to
her son is symptomatic of some religious
state Edmonds friend Florian for
instance is certain that quote religious
memory and rank fanaticism is the cause
of her separation from her son and he
denies any sort of moderation to women I
never knew a woman but loved our bodies
or our souls too well was one of the
great lines from last night he sees her
as a quote ruthless mother lacking
affection for her son while giving away
all of his riches to the church and when
Peter the porter speaks of his ladies
ever heaven directed I he's giving
support to the idea that maternal
feeling was spent somehow in religious
devotion
Florian's piety 'he's about motherhood
as an effective state do not allow him
to see that the
countess does not need to be rescued
from her monks the first scene between
Florian and Peter raises the pressing
question just how religious is she and
just how is she religious the monk
Martin is another one attached to his
dicot dichotomies in contrast to Florian
Martin reads the countess the countess
is refusal to take confession believe in
prophetic visions or take solace and
incantations as rank heresy Benedict
however realizes that simple dichotomies
mother monster st. or heretic don't
accurately explain her behavior she
thinks too much is too much a logician
and these he says or pagan virtues
although he's determined to use it to
Bad ends Benedict recognizes that
religious difference exists on a
spectrum and the countess confronts him
with aspects of the pagan and the
Christian the devotee and the heretic as
she reasons through her own perdition
because she's less mysterious to him
she's more malleable he can manipulate
her impulses and has seen glimmers of
success in that his prophecy sometimes
haunt her dreams
Peter the porter has seen her walk
around quote with frantic gesture and a
hurried step the philosopher countess it
seems has lapses for which she duly
chastises herself subtending the
dialogue between the countess and
Benedict many of those scenes we didn't
get to see last night probably because
they would have put us to sleep
our echoes of UMES natural history of
religion in which he posits that
primitive humans progressed from
polytheism to monotheism as they turn to
contemplating the natural order rather
than the relationship between
aberrations in the in the natural world
and its relationship to life in other
words the practice of interpreting
natural phenomena as harbingers of the
of events of life is a primitive impulse
however since neither polytheism nor
monotheism are inherently rational
humans may slip back into the quote
superstitious bigotries that we see very
much on display in Walpole's tragedy the
mysterious mother is always in danger of
slipping back into superstition and into
the momentary madness that led her to
bed her son later in the play
when wracked by grief she thinks she
sees her husband when she be holds her
son she hears ghosts she believes
herself dead
she asks her spells to relieve her
misery at other times she scoffs
heroically at Benedict and bests them
with logic and biting wit
in short she wavers traveling the whole
spectrum between skepticism and frenzied
enthusiasm Walpole succeeds in printing
presenting a character whose penitence
is not degraded by superstitious bigotry
in part by dramatizing her resistance
she says quote only weak minds weak
minds want their souls fortune told by
Oracle's and holy jugglers unquote her
religious opinions are one she's
reasoned into because of affliction
regarding her charity work she also says
quote I did not feel for others because
I did not think to feel for others
because I did not think by the end of
Act one it's established that the
countess's religious positions and
opinions on priests craft are far from
what they're reputed to be and that her
freedom from superstition depends on
maintaining a certain mental fortitude
her parent parental behavior operates on
a similar parallel spectrum the
countess's relationship to her son is
not as the other characters believe
dictated by her religious zealotry or
relationship to priests who as she says
Quayle before her Toni Bowers his term
effective motherhood and terms affect
his mother and economic motherhood are
useful starting points for understanding
the countess's maternal behavior
effective motherhood being unavailable
to her that is the feeling the nurturing
the hugging and the kissing she acts out
her parental role rather as a steward of
her son's ancestral wealth Benedict
reads this behavior as loveless he says
she loves him not yet mistress of his
fortunes she loves him not yet mistress
of his fortunes his ample exhibition
speaks her bounty she Destin's him what
error her father's love gave blindly to
her will Edmunds still believing that he
was banished for an affair with Beatrice
calls his mother rigid but denies she's
squandering his money he says to me her
hand is as bounteous as her heart is
cold
Walpole's play therefore it takes of
questions of maternal difference that
are present in other mother fictions of
the period Defoe's Roxana for instance
also reasons that economic motherhood
that is caring for the material needs of
the child is a meat substitute for
affect affection and nurturing neither
Roxana nor the countess are able to tend
to their children or love them in
conventional ways and both find their
religious systems of their birth to be
insufficient for supporting their
experiences or bearing them up under
trial where Roxana works out biblical
interpretations that support her
peculiar brand of motherhood Walpole's
countess assumes the role of the father
the ruler of lands money and children
has Benedict colter mistress of fortunes
economic stewardship might feel unloving
and Edmund certainly feels that it is
but the countess has earned his respect
through behaviors more immediately
associated with fathers like a medieval
or early modern chesterfield the
countess writes letters to her son
teaching him how to be a man these
letters seem to countermand her
reputation as a praying magnet Magdalene
Edmond says quote her letters Florian
such unstudied strains of virtuous
eloquence this praying Magdalene enjoins
my courage to emulate my great
forefathers deeds
tell me that shame and guilt alone or
mortal and death but bars the
possibility of frailty and in bombs
untainted honor
unquote in reaffirming his banishment
Sheehan joins him to obey her commands
and she speaks of her masculine soul she
has overall little respect for mothers
seeing them as dispensable or worse
trust me she tells Florian a father's
guardian arm were well worth all the
treasures that withheld a mother might
be spared indeed for the countess
motherhood is corruptible and has
brought her misery but fatherhood seems
possible straightforward indispensable
even and yet the mother cannot be spared
both Edmond and ad ELISA longed for
maternal affection for her part although
she cannot lavish Edmond with affection
the countess has overcome with
protective emotion at the sight of him
desperate to shield him in ad ELISA from
the knowledge of her sins
overcome with guilt the pull toward
effective motherhood moves separately
but in tandem with her backsliding into
superstition and madness
Georgina Locke had a great line last
night that did come through in the play
loved him own nature bleeding at my
heart right the nature is pulling at her
just by the words loved him or being
asked if she loves him the countess
resists certain kinds of natural
impulses both to superstition and to
effect only for as long as she can
remain mysterious as long as she seems
something unnatural or otherworldly and
The effect of her natural passions
remains hidden and in the effect of her
natural passions remains hidden and
insulated from manipulation like those
who experiences 1750 London earthquakes
the absurdities of whom Walpole wrote
about shortly after the shock of
terrible event events separates her from
her reason reason is no match for an
earthquake shared themes of oscillation
between reason and superstition light
and dark are what Diana beau Clarke's
drawings made why they're such fitting
illustrations for Walpole's play in her
drawings some of what you've already
seen up on the screen human characters
natural elements give them cover and
protection while also simultaneously
reaching out to draw them into the
darkness this darkness is a retreat and
a cover but it also has an ominous and
creeping and inescapable quality they
sanitize a topic that Walpole admitted
was disgusting he adored Beau Clarke's
drawings because he said they're
expressive but quote they do not shock
like the original unquote the drawings
have this ability to express the
interplay between reason nature
penitence and superstition in a way that
separates them from the incest plot that
propels those themes in the play their
emblems of his ideas and in a way
they're a guide to reading the
mysterious mother right thank you
thank you so much Nicole our next
speaker is Cheryl Nixon she is an
associate provost at the University of
Massachusetts Boston she also serves as
an associate professor of English
specializing in 18th century literature
the rise of the novel and law and
literature she is the author of the
orphan in 18th century law and
literature estate blood and body
published by Ashgate in 2011 in addition
to editing an anthology of commentaries
on the novel novel definitions she's
published articles on topics such as
guardianship and legal record-keeping
and I was inspired by this glimpse into
her activities as a scholar and teacher
and citizen she comments gel comments
that her favorite form of scholarship
has been creating public rare book
exhibitions with her students for the
Boston Public Library including the
exhibit crow crooks rogues and maids
less than virtuous books in the streets
of 18th century London and her her talk
today is about not the mysterious mother
but the mysterious orphan in this play
great thank you
and I think you can tell with the
emphasis on the idea that orphan in my
scholarship that indeed I will emphasize
the idea of the orphan so I guess my
topic is not that mysterious
so in this mini paper I'd like to turn
us to a reading of the mysterious mother
that emphasizes the perspective of the
child I'd like to argue that the play
dramatizes the family's ability to
recreate the child and more specifically
the parents ability to redefine the
biological child as an orphan
obviously I'm emphasizing the countess's
positioning of her child at Eliza as an
orphan but I would also like to
emphasize her positioning uppers
on Edmund as an exile a symbolic orphan
barred from his home and mother
resulting from this redefinition of the
family the play dramatizes the orphans
feelings of loss and confusion feelings
of powerlessness place lessness
selflessness simply put the mothers
purposeful transformation of her child
into an orphan is an obvious act of
familial betrayal and I would like us to
see orphan it as a shocking act of
betrayal although of course we focus on
incest as the plays most horrible act of
betrayal I'm going to argue that
orphanage is just as striking and
shocking so let me convince you that
orphanage is one of Walpole's key
concerns in the play I'll emphasize
three points that the orphan is a
duplicated figure throughout the play
so therefore it it offers structure to
the play that orphanage II of familial
reconfiguration that furthers incest s--
familial redefinition so orphanage kind
of on the spectrum with incest and
orphanages the activity of
interpretation and the idea of unequal
knowledge unequal power in that act of
interpretation so obviously there's a
duplication of orphan figures throughout
the play so that we do not miss the idea
of the orphan
I'll make the obvious point that the
orphan is repeated and becomes a way of
structuring character emphasizing the
children's dependent relationship on the
countess although we are used to
emphasizing the countess's emotions the
play obviously emphasizes the emotion of
the children at Eliza and Edmund the
pain of homelessness the pain of not
knowing one's parents of being rejected
of being exiled so with ADD Eliza the
orphan ward overseen by the countess is
obviously our key figure here and
there's many many quotes I could read
but I'm just going to pick a few key
quotes for each character at Eliza
emphasizes the mystery of family origins
that
she represents and she's constantly sort
of questioning who are my parents where
am i coming from so here's just one
example of that that occurs early in the
play
the countess says thou dearest orphan to
my bosom come and vent thy little
sorrows and at Eliza continues when then
ultimately says when have I wept but
when thou hast refused to let that add
Eliza call the mother I know I was not
worthy of such an honor - splendid for a
child of charity I know I am most
unworthy so and of course you know we
know that that ad Eliza's verging on
truth by wanting to call her the mother
but that kind of confusion and weeping
and saying I am not unworthy but I want
to call you my mother that sort of
confusion of feelings I think what a
while pulls emphasizing here I'll move
on to Edmund as an exiled child I'd like
to also argue that he plays a bit of a
role of an orphan also my researches on
the legal orphan and legally a child
whose inheriting in a state if the
father dies they would have legally been
considered an orphan unless the mother
had been specifically named as the
guardian of the child I think that
probably would have been the case in
this in this story because of the way as
we were just hearing that the countess
oversees the estates of Edmund however I
think we want to emphasize that it would
have been very common for a child that
lost a father to have been sort of put
in the category of orphan in the 18th
century and when we first meet Edmund he
emphasizes this banishment this sort of
rejection by his mother so he sort of is
dual Edie parented this is of course the
obvious scene that we saw last night
where he describes stealing into
beatriz's chamber and that's where again
we know that it's a it's verging on the
understanding of incest that he's not
quite seeing quote how my mother became
apprised I know not but her heart never
to partial to me grew estranged
estranged a version in its fellows mood
scowled from her eye and drove me from
her sight she called me in pious named
my honest lewdness a profanation of my
father's ashes I knelt and wept and it
continues on talking about bathing her
hand with tears and how she snatches it
away and how it's horrible so very
overwrought emotions later Florian asks
why would you return why do you return
to this why do you want to return home
and admin says I am weary Florian of
such a vagrant life we heard that line
last night also so that sense of feeling
estranged rejected weary the excess of
emotion Edmunds constantly referring to
that I'd like to emphasize as another
example of the repetition of orphans the
chorus of orphans that we heard briefly
last night and sort of had a shadowy
figure of some figures up on the screen
representing the orphans obviously here
I think that while Walpole is doing a
very over-the-top duplication of the
idea of the orphan so that we do not
miss we do not miss the figure of the
orphan they witness supernatural
evidence of the family's sin and they
importantly do not understand it so this
will be a point that I'll emphasize a
little bit later in the paper
the countess when she first introduces
the orphans calls them my little orphans
these are part of as a benefactress who
is benefitting from her charity and the
orphans sing a hymn I'll just read the
last two stanzas of the hymn but I want
to emphasize here is that they are
playing the role of sort of facing or
covering up the family crime also so the
orphans hymn goes here us harmless
orphans here for who for who who dries
our falling tear hush her sorrows calm
her breasts give her what she gives us
rest guard are spotless souls from sin
grant us virtues palm to win clothe the
penitent with grace and guilts foul spot
if face if face so here obviously
they're positioning themselves in
relationship to the countess they're not
her children but in a way they are her
children her they're her little orphans
that are trying to come up with a way to
calm her breast to hush her sorrows and
obviously they end with that line
they're trying to efface her guilt and
the foul spots on her
so the orphan becomes a cover or a mask
for the source of guilt so we could
continue to analyze each of these
characters in greater depth but what I
want to emphasize is that the orphan is
a larger structure and sort of
structuring the obsessions of the play
and orphanage as a strategy my second
point is that orphanage is a strategy a
film a familiar reconfiguration that
furthers the incest theme or fitting
provides another example of Walpole
exploring the limits of family bonds and
asking what is the breaking point of the
family the countess's activity of
redefining the child as an orphan
parallels or compounds the crime of
incest as we were just hearing I think
we're very comfortable asking what's the
source of the countess's pain and
emphasizing that hidden idea of incest
and I think that we also want to
emphasize this questioning that is
coming from the children why did she
banish Edmund and who has adelies as
parents the sort of incest question
leads to these further questions that
involve the children orphanage not just
another example of her immoral
manipulation of thing of the family but
provides an example of her conscious
decision to extend that manipulation to
give it structure and permanence by
making it an overt part of her family
the countess believes that orphanage can
hide her crime of incest in effect
provide a solution to the incest
however we know this is twisted logic I
think as good readers we know any
solution like this is only going to come
found and further that original crime
and not succeed in masking it and what I
would like us to consider is that the
crime of purposeful offer orphanage is
in some ways even more horrific than
incest for two reasons first because
it's an expression of excess excess
excessive desire of course leads to the
incest but also leads to and is
accompanied by this excessive rejection
of the child so in some ways these two
opposites are yoked together through
orphanage excessive desire and excessive
rejection but I want to emphasize
they're both excessive they're both very
over-the-top because of this duplication
of orphanage and secondly because it's
not just a singular occurrence the or
fitting becomes a daily occurrence it's
a form of family betrayal that's
repeated and what I want to emphasize
this becomes routine eyes normalized
it's a planned form of excess again it's
even in those that group of orphans that
she sort of positions an entire chorus
of orphans that are receiving her
charity it becomes sort of normalized
and that's the horror is that it's
become daily it's become routine it's
planned excess the so as my third point
I want to emphasize that orphanage is
connected to the activity of
interpretation the orphan introduces the
unknown into the family who are your
parents who are your siblings where did
you come from where are you going the
orphan is a mystery that needs to be
solved and these characters are
constantly questioning who am i because
of their orphan status the orphan just
thus heightens are interested in
interpreting the family as readers we
want to determine what is its true
structure what is its true meaning the
orphanage keeps teasing us to try to
interpret what is at the heart of this
family I would like to emphasize again a
seemingly unimportant element of the
play this chorus of orphans these
orphans emphasize the active
interpretation because they witnessed
the supernatural destruction of the
monument to the cow
of an Arbonne they asked us to question
what does this mean what does this
supernatural moment mean so I'll just
read kind of a brief excerpt from that
scene the orphans are going in to sort
of see the count of Nar bones Monument
and the first orphan says Oh a storm so
dreadful some demon rides the air and
continues describing the storm Martin
says twas well but none of you in the
orphans none of you had the courage to
face the fiend to face the specter they
continued a bit back and forth and the
second orphan says I winked I saw the
lightning burst on the monument the
shield of arms shivered to splinters ere
I could repeat an Ave Maria down came
the hideous crash the cross came
tumbling and then I fled and Martin says
retire this is unholy ground
so with mast mate we had that image of I
really liked that there was that image
of the broken monument kind of hovering
over most of the play that symbolic
representation of the Father and in his
response to what's happening in the
family
what is this broken mind man why is it
broken
and I think it's important that the
orphans this group of orphans are
pointing to that Monument
thus orphan Assizes a lack of knowledge
about the family and it also emphasizes
unequal knowledge and unequal power in
that active interpretation orphan amazes
questions that need to be answered but
the answers are unclear of course here
we know it's only the countess that has
the true answers or fitting raises
confusion about parentage confusion
about place confusion about the role in
the family so when Edmund is seeing his
mother for the first time we know and
I'll just list a couple of key quotes
the countess responds and we saw this
again stage last night the countess says
ha is this sorcery or is it my husband
and Edmund replies your parent mother
sort of correcting her saying no I am
your sign you know you are my mother so
the the a lack of knowledge about the
family leads to confusion leads to
displacement of the positions of the
family another example as adelies a--
says alas when I was then both the child
of sin who were my parents I must pray
for them but she does not know who her
parents are and the countess obviously
will not tell her a key moment of course
is the horror of learning about
parentage when that question of orphan
against answered it also answers the
question with the with incest so I'll
just read a little bit from that key
scene when Edmonds is confronting his
mother with his marriage and Edmond says
dear parent look on us and bless your
children and the countess replies my
children horror horror yes to sure ye
are my children again that sort of
claiming that these are not orphans but
these are her children she's doing that
with this full knowledge that involves
incest whereas of course at this moment
Edmond doesn't understand what that
claiming means okay and she continues
Edmond loose thy hand tis poison to thy
soul hell has no venom like a child's
touch o agonizing thought who made this
marriage whose unhallowed breath
pronounced the incestuous sounds and
that's where we get that word incest but
I think I want us to emphasize that
before we get to the moment of incest we
get to the claiming of the child we get
to the question of resolving orphanage
and we get this unique repetition of the
naming of familial position throughout
this entire scene so let me be a little
bit more of the scene and again
emphasizing that there has to be this
naming and renaming a familial position
because people the characters are trying
to interpret what is happening and
there's this unequal knowledge where the
countess understands the true familial
positions but the children do not and so
the countess continues lo we
there this mother stands where excuse me
where this monster stands thy mother
mistress
the mother of thy daughter sister wife
the pillar of accumulate accumulated
Horrors so she has to run through all of
these positions within the family she's
a monster because she's a mother
mistress daughter sister wife right all
of us collapsed together and trying to
figure out the correct structuring of
the family and again I would argue that
it's not just incest but it's orphanage
that has created this familial confusion
so to conclude as I hope I've shown the
orphan is central to determining the
logic of Walpole's horror it's central
to the structuring of the play this is
obviously a play about familial horror
about familial betrayal this horror
comes from the ability to redefine and
restructure the family but I would argue
it's a restructuring that occurs not
just through incest but through
orphanage
[Applause]
Thank You Cheryl our last speaker is
Nicole M right Nicole is an assistant
professor of English at the University
of Colorado at Boulder she was recently
a Lapidus long-term fellow at the
Schomburg Schomburg Center at the New
York Public Library her articles have
appeared in 18th century fiction 18th
century studies the 18th century theory
and interpretation the Toronto quarterly
and the Chronicle of Higher Education
she will speak today to us on kindest
laws intimate adjudication in the
mysterious mother Thank You Jill for the
introduction and thank you to Cindy
Nicole Michelle and Sue for all they did
to prepare for this event and to the
Lewis Walpole library for fostering some
of my earliest navigations of the
archive and it's Serendipity's that term
that Walpole popularized well awful
silence
Florian exclaims at the beginning of the
mysterious mother with this sentence the
very first act the very first line of
the first act
Florian breaks the prevailing quiet even
has he directs attention to it the
descriptor awful compounds the
suggestion the holding intention of
opposing meanings simultaneously
keynoting the awe and reverence with
which the faithful approached God and
the dread evoked by the untold tale
prior to the countess's ghastly
revelation from the very beginning then
while post tragedy Prime's its audience
to balance dueling sensory conditions
and affective states silence and
cacophony piety and disgust and
disgusting is one of the terms that
Walpole notably uses when discussing his
play and correspondence
the Janus face phrasing of the first
line precedes an abundance of similar
locations throughout the play such
moments resume as cues to the plays
audience of readers bringing to mind at
once original integrity and post-slap
Syrian brokenness essential honor and
innate depravity as the play continues
thus becomes clear that it's dialogue
reflects a model for moral judgment
establishing its readers as alternative
arbiters who can evaluate the countess's
crime of incest with more perspicuity
than allowed by the villain of the piece
friar Benedict the predatory confessor
the countess is striving for atonement
more specifically her struggle to take
back or compensate for her crime has a
formal analog I argue in the terminology
of simultaneous reiteration and erasure
that pervades the play as the countess
alternately hints at discloses and
renounces her wrongful deed certainly
the countess can be reviled as a
nymphomaniac who embed in her duty to
mourn her venerable husband on the very
night his bloody corpse is delivered to
her no less and instead satisfies her
urges by deceiving her own son into
carnal embrace yet her unceasing efforts
to serve the most vulnerable members of
her community and repent for her crime
are also foregrounded via not only the
plot but also the diction and syntax of
the plays dialog the plays moral double
vision is also sustained through the
countess's habit of palem Cystic
inscription in which she composes
messages that she subsequent that she
subsequently crosses out or weeps over
to the point that they are almost
illegible but can still be read in full
by those who come into possession of her
works as I will show the countess and
her children together produced not only
a transgression that can be regretted
but never obliterated but also a model
for how lay people ought to deliberate
over even the most apparently profound
crimes and note that the countess
to use crime rather than sin distinction
that is significant for my argument the
model they demonstrate abstains from
judgment from a distance from rich
characterological nuances cannot be
perceived and instead privileges
intimate adjudication that takes into
consideration pound Sestak moral
complexity to make up an account to use
the phrase favored by the friar martin
friars Martin and Benedict I argue that
the problem confronted by the plays
audience how to judge this sensational
episode of double incest is eliminated
by the template of judgment that the
countess and Edmund generate for
assessing those in a variety of
circumstances ranging from the poor
souls who flock to share in the
countess's benevolence to the supposed
infidels who fall to Edmunds sword as
they vie for power and sovereignty with
Christians and far-off lands so where
else do we see this model of judgment
this moral priming emerging on the page
one manifestation can be found in the
prefix Sun which is repeatedly
associated with the crime as she terms
it of the countess
quick on sale in monstrous tale the
countess please upon hearing that her
children ELISA and Edmund have been
united in matrimony by Benedict the
profusion of Unterman toned by the
countess reflect her futile yearning for
her present words to nullify her
previous actions
she asks Benedict whether he has come to
tutor my uh knab's nature a face the
stains or is her attempt really in vain
for an voguing the impossibility of
returning to her previous condition of
rectitude and dignity her pleas
seemingly ineffectual in the world of
the play can conjure for the audience of
readers a double vision not only of her
crime but also for prior integrity and
current virtue the skewing the audience
to gauge how practical practicable it
would be to unsay the tale even if such
a possibility is this
nearly as soon as it is Reyes referring
to herself as the UH napped unhinged
unnatural perpetrator of this secrets in
this untold tale the countess
disassociates herself with from several
desirable honorable qualities but the
humility and reason with which she
speaks of what Benedict Benedict calls
her unheard of crimes calls into
question rather than reaffirms the
notion that she cannot find redemption
after all other Unruh Versalles are
performed upon demand as when edmond
orders Benedict unriddle priest my soul
is too impatient to wait the
impertinence of flowery dialect or as
when Florian later commands the friar by
my good sword thou shalt unriddle priest
the uninjected are reminiscent of
similar contemplations of more leaf
rated reversal and Shakespeare whose
literary influence on the mysterious
matter mother has long been noted from
Kent's reply and leer I cannot wish the
fall undone referring to the birth of
his natural son also named Edmond to
Lady Macbeth's unsex me here and fill me
to the crown from the crown to the toe
top-full of direst cruelty and here you
can see how this connects up with the
rewriting of Macbeth that Dale mentioned
earlier in the Shakespearean context
these wishes are demands for moral
reversals may be repented of
retroactively Lee denied or incompletely
fulfilled but in each case the speaker's
original morally blameless state is
brought to mind even if only through an
utter decay ssin alongside their current
moral condition to further complicate
matters note that uh niz what linguists
call a bound morpheme bound because it
does not stand on its own as a word and
morpheme for its power to radically
morph change reverse the word it
modifies the prefix on though is in bit
ambiguous in that wallet sometimes
connotes the reversal of some original
condition it does not necessarily do so
it can either negate an excellent
condition
or indicate that a given condition never
existed in the first place
while the guilt-ridden contest
frequently uses Unwerth so does her
blameless daughter Atalissa
for the countess on means reversal for
add Alisa unsustainable moral purity
that remains intact at least until she
is wed to her brother Edmund prior to
her unnatural union add ELISA is a
maiden of unblemished innocence she is
unknowing and unfriend and unfriended
linguistically linked through terms of
negation the guilty mother and the
innocent daughter blur together as both
are associated with original moral
goodness and dignity even Benedict who
presents himself as the plays moral
arbiter Foster's this bifurcated
split-screen view of the countess during
one of their frequent arguments he
taunts her before announcing the false
news of Edmunds death learn if the
mother's fortitude can brave the ball
the woman's arrogance to 5 here Benedict
divides the countess into the proud
self-serving woman and the
long-suffering sacrificial mother
elsewhere however Benedict defines the
countess solely in terms of her crime
her met his methodology of judgment is
presented as one that the reader must
reject he judges through gossip
deduction and insinuation Benedict steps
in as an arbiter to take advantage of
the failure of law law and the
mysterious mother is invoked primarily
as a disempowered neutered force that
which fluorine refers to as nature's
kindest laws elocution who's very
tautology evokes the play's double
incest has led the countess and Edmund
astray as they follow their instinctive
desires to satisfy their sexual
appetites Edmund prides himself on the
fact that he has quote not sapped my
country's laws unquote but these laws
likewise failed to protect him from
perdition Benedict disavows any
responsibility to follow the laws of
nation or
the church he states no laws I know but
my but her prosperity no country but her
boundless acquisitions despite his
apparent piety he has ruled not by
theological considerations but instead
by his avarice it is indicative of the
countess's reinstated moral capacity
that she resists his efforts to stand in
judgment of her as her confessor as
Robert Myles notes the play advocates
for the sanctity of the individual
conscience a self-assertiveness against
the invasive power of the patriarchal
confession rejecting the modes of
judgment offered by the law the play
instead advocates for intimate
adjudication a practice relying on
relying on proximity and familiarity in
addition to the aforementioned capacity
to remain mindful not only of a person's
current fallen state but also of their
potential for goodness sometimes this
intimate adjudication takes the form of
embodied practice an ELISA judges the
con with the count tests best when she
knows her least before she knows that
she is her mother she can discern her
moral capacity through the gentleness
with which the count test brushes away a
tear on a chief for her part the
countess admits that before she
regularly indirectly interacted with the
less fortunate of her community she
misjudged them viewing them through the
lens of privilege akin to the just world
hypothesis as it is now called she she
admits and if a pensive visit crossed my
path I deemed the we're in envious or
ill-natured after her husband's death
however she immerses herself in the
community of the poor and ceases to
judge others so harshly Benedict
acknowledges that the Healing Touch for
which the countess is known is beyond
his own skill set when the countess
refuses to divulge her secret to him in
act 1 he recommends that she attend
another holy man whose sanctity is
marked by his gifts miracles spring from
his touch yet for the countess judging
and redeeming those who have who have
made mistakes is not a matter of extreme
measures of lengthy pilgrimages and rear
miracles
instead it involves everyday embodied
practice listening to a tale wiping away
a tear the model of judgment endorsed by
the plate endorsed by the play
encourages refraining from judging those
with whom one cannot encounter in
regular familiar proximity recounting
his participation in battles with
Turkish soldiers over territory that
would later come to be known as Budapest
Edmund asks and this is a quote from the
quotation from the play beef it's at me
sprung from a race of heroes in our
bonds Prince to lend my casual arms
approved valor to korells nor my
country's nor my own sustain my sword of
random blood I found up boot against the
Turk I smoked the turbaned race did zeal
or did an ambition nerve my blow or
matter it to me on Buddhist domes well
rather the Crescent or the cross
prevailed Hedden asks whether he should
have abstained from intervening and
corals to which he is not a party
applied more broadly he asked whether
one should judge those whom one does not
know whose redeeming qualities are not
known and cannot be invoked to balance
against their suppose at crimes his
question recalls the practice of
judgment endorsed in letter from Soho a
Chinese philosopher in London to his
friend Lee and she at Peking which
Walpole published in 1757 a year before
he completed the mysterious mother in
that letter the Chinese philosopher of
the title disapproves of the way in
which the English conduct trials but his
apparent disapproval is tempered by his
explicit Demerol from judgment reason in
China he writes is not reason in England
my friend Len XI I tell thee things as
they are I pretend not to account for
the conduct of the Englishmen I told
thee before they are incomprehensible
while Peter Kitson has suggested that
the letter espouses quote the view that
China was or could
the locus of moral authority as opposed
to a corrupt Britain I see the letter as
exemplifying a universe of universally
available mode of judgment given Edmunds
explicit aversion to imposing his own
judgment on those he does not know the
unusual history of Narbonne a an area
that had at different points substantial
Jewish and Muslim populations may shed
more light on Walpole's mysterious
tragedy some earlier critics did not
devote much attention to the
significance of the area in which the
play takes place in her 1974 critical
edition of the mysterious mother Janet
Adel Dolan asserts sitting setting in
the mysterious mother is relatively
unimportant as far as plot is concerned
while Paul chose to locate his play in
narbonne a region in southern France she
leaves it at that yet Narbonne has a
steep centuries-old history as a site of
religious toleration and non-judgement a
place where non-christian persons could
at various points live in harmony and
practice their faith without legal
restrictions or persecution without
being judged for what they believe
Narbonne is an important site for Jewish
and Muslim as well as Christian history
reflecting a critical mass of
scholarship on the subject the scholar
benzion Netanyahu contends that in the
700s Narbonne played an unprecedented
role in the history of European Jewry in
the mysterious mother the countess
argues that a person should be judged by
their good works not by their faith
countering Benedict's dictates similar
privileges of works as a measure by
which characters should be judged
facilitated the thriving of the Jewish
community of Narbonne in the 700s they
were lauded by the king for sharing
their wealth for the public good
recognizing the services rendered by the
Jews in relieving that economic distress
of his Empire Charles overruled decrees
enacted by against the Jews by Christian
legislators and granted the Jews of
Narbonne basic freedoms and the full
protection of his government exemption
from judgment the judgment of bigotry
judged by their war
rather than by their faith the Jewish
inhabitants of Narbonne were able to
live in harmony with Christians for
several decades indeed at some points
non-christians ruled Narbonne for a four
decade period in the 700s Islamic forces
gained control of the area and used it
as a base for military campaigns inside
a Catholic Church they built a mosque
through its setting then the play
reiterates Walpole's own call in his
other writings for reason to replace
bigotry in judging those of different
faiths as when he defended the so-called
Jew Bill of 1753 which would have
expanded the rights of Jewish people
living in England but was repealed Deutz
native native this sentiment and there
are other examples of authors writing
reiterating the debate over the Jew bill
in the early 1760s to be qualified to
judge others adequately the mysterious
mother suggests one would do well to
practice intimate adjudication to define
a person not only by a singular crime
but also by the balance of their
character to interact frequently and
directly of others whom one judges and
to refrain from judging those in
communities with whom one does not enjoy
close acquaintances perhaps the kind
kindest law for would-be judges to keep
in mind the play suggests is to remain
cognizant of the extent to which they
remain on or at least not yet
kind thank you
so who would like to get our discussion
started
Natacha just like remind you thank you
hello can you hear me well thanks so
much to all of you for your papers which
were really stimulating and
thought-provoking just because it's on
my mind I have a question about the last
paper I was wondering I guess I was just
wondering if you could reflect a little
bit on the relationship between
adjudication and the mystery structure
which might also sort of be a point of
contact with some of the other papers I
was thinking about how the prefix unn
has both the two qualities that you
pointed out so that it can sort of
cancel something out that's already
happened be a kind of retroactive
negation it can be what was the second
one a sort of state of pure purity or
non-existence and then it seems to me
that the third that might be relevant
for the mystery plot is that it can be a
kind of anticipatory on so unheard can
be something that isn't yet sort of
spoken and and I guess I was just
wondering it was very interesting to me
to think about the play as staging a
scene of judgment or a kind of
alternative confession in some way as
opposed to the sort of epistemological
question that is at the heart of the
mystery so this sort of how does it sort
of sort of maybe more pre an interest in
just what is true how does that
intersect with those sort of moral
questions that your
thank you and I do think that
connotation is certainly that third
connotation certainly is there as well
and one thing I noticed is especially in
the roughly the first half of the player
so is you see this this prefix on
invoked by the countess in ways that
tantalizes others whether consciously or
unconsciously to know more about her
tale to draw it out of her and I also
I'm also kind of thinking about how that
connects up with the with the
composition history of the mysterious
mother to that Dale mentioned this
alternating disclosure and retrench me
in which law pull himself engages on
this notion that we're anticipating this
disclosure that hasn't yet arrived
a misty
thanks everyone for those papers I have
a question for Matthew but it might fan
out I think you don't know a beautiful
job of showing us that sort of queer
space of a Gothic obsession in Walpole
in that kind of bifurcation which we
talked about a little yesterday between
the aesthetic Catholicism aesthetic that
is Catholic and a theology that's
Catholic I'm wondering if and I realize
you're coming at this as an art
historian but is there a kind of queer
theology that these that this crypto
Catholicism is as articulating that
that's more than just the sort of
same-sex erotic space like if there's a
sort of properly theological queerness I
think that there definitely is whether
Walpole understood it to be as such I
I'm unless I'm less certain and there is
of course a growing debate about this in
terms of scholarship on on camp and
performance and the extent to which
these things offer rather than seeing
campus something that's kind of facile
and simply just performative for the
sake of performance but actually camp
offers a really kind of vital and
serious way of actually engaging with
these issues outside of any other kind
of performative mode so I think that may
be a really interesting way to start
into this because things like these
masses that they actually do are at
least in terms of waffle circle quite
odd and quite strange and I can't think
of many others that are done with at
least a certain degree of reverence
because in that particular letter
Walpole says that they had some mass as
they pull down some mass because I had a
really good time with incense and then
they went and played cards you know and
so so there is a kind of in the letter a
it does actually lead you from something
which is quite sacred to something which
is quite literally you know fun but I
shouldn't I don't think that actually
diminishes the first part of that which
is important to me so I in my own work
I've tried to come back to this a little
bit more gravity if that answers your
question
just to get back to that I think a lot
of the work of 18th century gothic is
actively to queer Catholicism both as an
as a kind of institution or a historical
practice but also as a theology and what
happens in you know in something like
Lewis's the monk the figure of Mary is
queered and there's a an erotic
relationship that ambrosia has with with
the figure of of Mary that you know
that's to exclude all of those fantasies
about same-sex queer desiring in spaces
like convents and monasteries and love
in a convent one of the things that
they're but they're there I think
Protestant writers of gothic are
certainly involved in the kind of
queering of Catholicism I think David
that's a good question and the mic so
well next to Michael orphanage as a
deliverance out of power
really and so I'm just trying to think
but do you have any other examples I'm
just trying to run through all my
eighteenth-century plays I know them you
know there's suddenly the orphan yeah
the way that you've described it is very
very powerful
so Arthur any of the novels or plays
that you found where the
there's you usually it's the opposite
where the there's that mystery that no
one knows and it gets revealed at the
end and I'm trying to think of one that
involves a mother that is actively
orphanage I am NOT coming up with more
off the top of my head I don't know if
anybody else can think of any but I'll
I'll keep pondering it I think that the
structure though of this figure that is
clearly has a mystery about their
parentage we know that's at the heart of
so many 18th century texts and that that
does wind up I think really working its
way into the Gothic and winds up being a
sort of a key way of structuring
multiple mysteries and I would say kind
of get concentrating then got
concentrated then in the orphan itself
and I'm just trying to think of like
lots of the novels of Charlotte Smith
for example focus on an orphan figure
that ultimately you know has to be
reclaimed of thing I guess all of the
novels of Boerne oh we could we could
probably start naming lots of them of
that sense of a rejected child being
reclaimed but usually it revolves around
the father figure and not such a
purposeful orphan encountered ya later
Bleak House I mean I think the Bleak
House gives us that sort of post 18th
century clarity of how important
orphanage is to the structuring of the
family and sort of again bringing in all
the legal aspects of orphanage so but I
think that's why I would say that's why
maybe this play I would I mean I think
we could probably continue to think of
examples but I say that is one of the
things that makes us play horrific in a
way is that it is because of a mother
purposely choosing to orphan a child so
if we think of incest as sort of one
pole of sort of a horrific act a parent
should never do I think the sort of
willful sort of disclaiming of a child
and positioning a child as an orphan is
another so horrific act so yeah and I'm
just gonna pick up and
and connected that something Nicole
talked about Nicole Garrett just that it
was so interested Cheryl that you
described it with a father's death even
if the mother's surviving legally in
most cases that would make a child in an
orphan but as you say the countess in a
way is acting like a father in in her
act of orphanage her own child is so
much more common in like Evelina
evil-ina has been in effect disclaimed
right her father and asked him so I'm
interested in the idea of the countess
as a mysterious father but there's some
way with she is part of her crime as
being more like a father than a mother
or in those crazy relations where the
incest doubles mother mistress mother of
your sister daughter wife that that
already the the countess has somehow put
herself in a position of the death
father and I just wondered if any of you
Cheryl or and/or Nicole or other women I
think it's not it's not very uncommon in
fictions that feature single mothers for
them to take on part of that role or to
resist that role and also for it to be
regardless of the the familial situation
or the money situation to be seen as
unnatural and masculine so we see that
with Roxana it's in Sidney bit off I
don't know if in the natural daughter
you could call that willful orphanage
financing it was one of the ones that
came to mind but there's usually there's
this little choice in the matter so this
is going going back into the last
question a little bit so thinking about
the fatherhood what is intriguing to me
is at what point does she become a
father and whether we can connect that
to the the original incest act does she
become a tyrannical gothic father
along the lines of the count of Narbonne
you know in the Jefferson play later at
the moment that her husband dies and is
that why she's capable of that act is it
is it you know there's sort of this
situation where she she moves from the
maternal and the female into the
paternal and and gothic sort of
fatherhood I'm not really sure but in
terms of behaving like a father that is
just something that comes up in single
mother fictions of the period a lot and
that they really do try to wrestle with
in in a number of different ways I think
I would build on that and say it
probably she steps into that role of the
tyrannical father when she banishes
Edmunds it's that that's a decision to
remove him which again I would say is
sort of an orphanage like yeah like act
but that seems to be where she's really
positions herself as powerful but I
think that the play is very interested
in in thinking through economic kind of
motherhood fatherhood way in the
gendering of that but also the emotions
I mean I think that that's where it's I
think a lot of fun the way it was put up
on the stage last night sort of a
highlight this idea of the the emotions
of the mother at some points she can be
serve imperious and take on this sort of
masculinity but at other points she
seems you know to be very feminine
fainting and shocked we think it's
containing vestiges of Lear which I see
everywhere in the play there's also
echoes of the rejection of Cordelia
right but I think like the genre or the
mode that he inaugurates I think
Walpole's work is thoroughly preoccupied
with what we might call the paternal
function so rather than actual
biological paternity he has an interest
in what you know much later
psychoanalysts will call the paternal
metaphor or the kind of range of
functions usually wielded by a father
who's not necessarily the biological
father and I think what Walpole what
happens in both the trans hair and hear
that
elsewhere in Walpole is that he's
interested in drawing a very firm
distinction between an outdated version
of the paternal function a tyrannous
perverse father like manfred and a trans
own with whom or he juxtaposes in a
trance a range of enlightened fathers
who are much more sentimentally engaged
in to weep when they're reconciled to
their children so there's a very firm
distinction between types of fathers in
a transfer but I think that follows
through to the mysterious mother where
you have an outdated version of the
paternal function of kind of tyrannous
father the father of perverse enjoyments
that Freud will talk about in total man
sebou in the form of fathers or friars
Benedict and Martin associated with the
Catholic past nonetheless you remove the
paternal function in the form of the
counts and in a pre-empting
psychoanalytic accounts of desire and
the law and paternity incest erupts when
you've moved that the the eatable that
the paternal function so she has to kind
of step into the role of a reformed
father reformed in all senses of that
word in order to keep the paternal
function and with that law the
circulation of desire etc operating so I
think what Paul is is deeply interested
in the paternal function and drawing
distinctions between kind of you know
very bland he put good and bad fathers
so she gets to be both types of father
they were formed in the yeah and the
outdated introducing the Walpole
constructing his own life multiple
fathers Horace Mann clearly is one of
these yes many many others you know in
my own work I've kind of explored both
family romance and queer family romance
this possibility of adopting a kind of
an alternate non-biological family but
could someone say something about
Walpole as an orphan not just his
contested parentage but the idea of
being an orphan also is a kind of
interesting queer metaphor in and of
itself potentially it could so much
speak to that I don't know would you
just say a little bit more about what
just go down the path you're going bed
as a queer metaphoric
a little bit more that's what you're
thinking okay the the in particular
cultures the orphan a queer child being
essentially kind of an orphan with with
often without family or your distance
from family for that reason and Walpole
zone contested parentage of course makes
him something potentially of an orphan
distance from his own father too so and
his rather emotional relationship with
his own mother which is also somewhat
contested so that's great I would take a
stab at that by saying that I think the
orphan allows there to be the active
construction of the family rather than
relying on biological bonds it's sort of
by erasing that as the main structure of
the family it opens up all these
possibilities for what is the structure
of the family going to be then if it's
not biological bonds it can be what you
want it to be so there's that it opens
up that possibility for queering I think
that's just a quick response but I think
that's what again is sort of being
played around with with the mysterious
mother if you're actively erasing family
bonds that are biological then what what
do you put in its place and I think that
could be something that's seen is
strategic in a way that I think you're
getting at that is empowering and I
think with the mysterious mother we see
the down side or the alternative of that
where it becomes a ultimately so it's a
source of power but ultimately it's
going to turn back in on itself and
become the very source of downfall so I
guess I'd want to think about it a bit
more I think that what I would say is
that without biological bhadra therefore
able to create bonds that are very
text-based or like you were emphasizing
ritual based it kind of opens up all
these other forms of constructing
relationships and sort of putting the
power and in those forms of construction
I must have not thought of it until I
heard your paper so thank you very much
pick up and a building off that I am
also thinking about as you say creating
textual bonds while poles work on the
writing of history and historiography
connected with the idea of the queer
entity and no future you know the
writing of history
as a substitute for biological progeny
no way but I think this comes across
strongly in the mysterious mother in
particular if we're going to think about
the orphan as a kind of queer figure
what is crucial is that the orphans
desire is not heed opalized and cannot
be utilized and it's D Territory alized
and kind of delusion and guattari and
sense but what is interesting is the
threat that that poses to any kind of
symbolic system because look at how ad
Eliza is continuously kind of coerced
into the convent or into a marriage the
desire has to be managed and indeed a
pearlized in a sense because she even
though she's she's not really an orphan
but she believes herself to be an orphan
her way of desiring exceeds beautiful
triangles and safely controllable modes
of desiring at the same time but it's
one thing that's strange to me about the
play is how often add Eliza's consent is
explicitly sought it's of course
disavowed or ignored later but there's
this explicit request do you consent at
least twice in the play I think we have
a couple more questions and just a tiny
bit more time so what I was good
Oh a lot of what I was going to ask her
so deep in covered the very lovely
discussion about Hornung I was going to
say something about incest actually the
unsay what I said yesterday about incest
being the worst thing after murder in
fact the thing that incest really harms
is the child I mean you know you could
get away with having incest if both
people were infertile and you're not
going to have children you know so um
and I also think that in that particular
familial environment if we're going to
call it that there is no there's no
respect for maternal or paternal love
you know so what's prioritized all the
time is sexual
and what we could call love or passion
you know and I do think that she is a
very masculine character one of the
things that she wants masculine but also
feminine she has to behave like a a man
because she wants the state you know she
wants to keep control of the state which
is I mean nobody's really covered the
fact that you know women and territory
it is very important and in a way I
think that's the way that she can hold
on to who she's pretending to be as long
as she's got that you know this is my
the other thing I'd like to say is that
actually anyone doesn't seem to give a
toss about his dad either you know I
mean they deserve you know nobody's
really looked at at what it's doing to
him to live in that environment
okay ends up being a sort of orphan as
well but you know he's got a a narrative
as as well and you know I think her her
journey if you want is about discovering
a degree of femininity in the way that
people understand femininity as beneath
men you know and one of the things that
she can defend herself from that is by
keeping control of the state she says
this state is mine and I will let you
know what I want to do with it thank you
very much you know so I think that
that's are very important especially at
that time I didn't what I don't know
what war people thought about that but I
mean I he's certainly looking at it you
know
I think the thing about incest that I
find intriguing and it takes takes me
back to Jill's wonderful article on the
play is that how heterosexual ins incest
in the late 18th century is often a
cipher for a much more unspeakable form
of desire which is homoerotic desire
it's the most visible of the so-called
sexual perversions which have yet to be
kind of named and constituted as such
but occupy the same office category
called sodomy in the period and and
heterosexual incest is often used as a
cipher for same-sex desiring certainly
in Walpole but also in Beckford and in
Lewes and that's what long ago what Paul
often links his love for his male
correspondents and his general you know
coterie of male friends to just just by
proximity in his letters to these often
kind of comic and grotesque anecdotes
about heterosexual incest Joe has a
question or a thought thank you yes I
was thrilling to hear these papers
individually in an ensemble of creating
a whole context world in Walpole's mind
in the theater and its various
contributed tarry features but before we
break I wonder if anyone has a kind word
for Sophocles exile return discovery the
mother gets it
he's right on the case early on maybe
even before the Corinthian messenger
arrives yeah the difference is of course
the level of intent and consciousness
with which the mother certainly commits
the first act of incest where there is
no unconscious in operation although you
know Elektra and feed hrus and you know
other clay plays in the classical
tradition certainly work their way into
the construction of of interest in the
play I think what Paul has been nervous
or bit anxious to engage too closely
with the classical tradition here
because of you know the broader
political imperatives of resisting
French neoclassicism and in the play so
he he instead will look as we discussed
last night to other models of tragedy
without necessarily reiterating or
following closely a classical tragic
formulas but there are certainly are
echoes there and this is as opposed
amplified by the fact that once woeful
has written the play several of his
friends and correspondence writings
saying oh I found a version of the story
in this text I found a version of story
in that text and several people are
almost without undermining his claims to
original genius suggestion did you know
that this happens here there and then he
claims with a lot of them not have known
about them but that only kind of
provides grist to his own mill that he
has successfully articulated something
archetypal and something that is in a
kind of cultural and conscious and
always has been and perhaps always will
be and in that way the the play itself
and aspires to a mythological status of
its own I think in this way in the way
that each of his has maybe you can even
think of it as Walpole or finning
self severing himself from this
classical literary genealogy because
remember he writes back and forth to
Mason who keeps encouraging him to
revise the count s character so she's
deceit so she doesn't know that she's
encountering her own son so there seems
to be some kind of disassociation of
that literary lineage and I would say
just our familiarity with with Sophocles
and I think all of us know that we're
reading an incest plot as soon as we
pick up the play but when I was watching
last night it was making me think I'm
was trying to imagine an original reader
which in some ways is sort of the theme
of this session and trying to imagine if
they would not have known that the
answer to the mystery was incest if they
were figuring it out much earlier in the
play or knew it before they even picked
up the play or if they would have been
sort of shocked at that moment of horror
when all is revealed towards the end so
I was and you know trying to think
through some of the papers as they were
beginning being given how much of the
readership would have known the
scandalous nature of the story before
they even picked up the play is probably
true but I was trying to figure out the
original reader / viewer of the play
would they have would they have known
the mystery or not I think we have time
just for this last question thank you so
much um so I have a question that is
specifically for Dale because your paper
got me thinking about the epigraph on
the title page of the 1768 from Virgil
which seems to just completely embody
the ambivalence of revealing and
concealing I translated it may it be
lawful for me to speak all that I have
heard and this is when the Sybil is
speaking in book 6 and I also think it's
interesting too because the Latin this
word Foss is actually in decline abble
so it has a type of ambivalence
in and of itself and I'm just wondering
if you consider that at all when you're
thinking about your paper firstly and
secondly what happens to that epigraph
over time because I think I saw it
disappear after the 1768 printing can
you read me the translation again what
is it this is my translation may it be
lawful for me to speak all that I have
heard okay and that word fuss is it
means like divine law or law or rule and
it's inclinable so I just sort of like
sitting on the line okay what is
interesting is is because I haven't
thought about the epigraph in in that
context but what is interesting is it
brings to mind his kind of mangling of
classical sources as epigraph in a
transfer and he sort of shifts an
epigraph and miss miss quad sets from
from a lesson source but the other thing
that that strikes me is that that seems
to be a classicist version of the same
sentiments that would be expressed by
the ghost of Hamlet's father in in
Hamlet I could a tale unfold in the kind
of I could a tale unfold that would
Harrow up thy soul freeze thy blood and
all the rest which becomes the kind of
mantra of Gothic writing after Walpole
so that sense of the ineffable if you
read it again the translation may it be
lawful for me to speak all that I have
heard and the Latin is sit mihi fast
I'll detail okey yeah the ineffable
things that come to mind are notions of
the ineffable about the kind of
subjunctive mood that we get in yep I
could a tale unfold in Hamlet's and a
kind of reserve of horror that is not
quite articulable discreet
that which lies beyond the powers of
language and indeed representation and I
think I think there is a concern in the
mysterious mother of the unrepresentable
and that which can only be kind of
circled by language there's a lot of
stuff that happens offstage that we
don't see and a lot of stuff that can't
be represented which you know later
becomes this concern with the ineffable
in Gothic writing so that's kind of how
I would approach that although I haven't
thoughts thoughts about the the epigraph
prospectively it also looks toward a
period of greater freedom in a certain
sense doesn't it that I will be able to
do these things and it actually really
arguably is actually a kind of a Latin
paraphrase or another version of fiery
qui sont yet or to say what one feels
which of course is you know waffles old
motto so potentially it is actually kind
of another version of that basic idea
about Liberty I suppose
I cut a little bit out of the prologue
that I recited at the beginning of the
performance yesterday which was actually
about how ridiculing the French who were
so rule-bound for having anything really
significant or horrific take place
offstage and here in England we don't
have to do that it doesn't have to be
reported by a Gazette
we are gonna you're gonna see it but
easier to just ascribe this problem to
the French then then actually in fact
Walpole this whole wonderful set of
papers makes me think he doesn't want to
simply put it before us he wants to
create a space where it you know as you
each brought out in different ways is
said and not said or unsaid or were
taken back where things are moving in
and out of the space and some some kind
of grasp ability knowing knowing is part
of the bed trick the countess knew more
than others knew and that's that's part
of the act of transgression thank you
all so much for coming today to help us
continue to contemplate this remarkable
and mysterious and very rich work and
please join me in thanking all of our
speakers for this just wonderfully rich
and suggestive ensemble as Joe put it of
papers
[Applause]
[Music]